let's jump into the first story we have
this from the new york post
biden dismisses uyghur internment camps
because we have to keep the language
family friendly
as part i can't even say that word no we
can't this oh goodness you can't say it
i'm writing it in my journal yeah yeah
yeah no
no no joke what's going on in in uh uh
china
we can't say it but what's the word how
do you what's the first and last letter
i guess oh yes yeah we could well
we can call them internment camps we can
call them forceful re-education centers
we can say that women are being held
down
while men come in and force themselves
upon the women
the women are undergoing forced
surgeries and
other extreme uh forced sterilization as
well as the forceful
this is time this is brutal there's some
there's more we should do it in the
bonus segment and just be
explicit there's so much more joe biden
when when asked about this
he basically said you know i'm not going
to criticize them cause you know they
got different culture
and i couldn't believe it what i could
not believe it
it makes me think of i i always hate
bringing up the nazis
i feel like they get too much publicity
as it is but the way that
the british appeased them and people
like they voted hitler time man of the
year
was it neville chamberlain neville
chamberlain was like he's in our time
yeah yeah let's give them
the su dayton land is that what it is
and then they were like and then if we
just give them this land they won't
they won't aggress anymore and like if
you give these totalitarian regimes and
give and give you just
you're just empowering biden is suckling
the teat of communism you know what to
do because the uh what's the other
option
war i don't know okay do we remember
back when donald trump
mentioned that we do bad things
remember and everybody was so mad that
he
questioned american exceptionalism
right that is an interesting case to
keep in mind when we look at this
because what happened with joe biden
is that he negated 50 years of american
foreign policy 50 years of american
political philosophy
50 years of us developing this notion of
universal human rights based on
sort of post-modern american liberal
values which are meant to be universal
in nature
which is why we went into iraq they said
which is why we went into afghanistan
they said which is why we went into
vietnam they said to push our universal
american values of
american liberalism yeah just in that
one moment
joe biden introduced the notion of moral
relativism
and he says hey they got a different
culture they do things a little bit
differently
immediately negating our entire
philosophical foreign policy position
immediately negating american
exceptionalism
and just neutering this idea of
universal liberalism
people around the world rejoice when he
hear joe biden say something like that
well his words were very important
because it was almost as
as he was excusing the activities he was
talking about china's history whenever
china wasn't united they were attacked
from the outside
and he talked about how this is the
cultural norms well if it's your
cultural
norm to strip down and have men forced
on women to have
four sterilization camps and tournament
camps i'm trying to wash my words
on unrequested insemination yes yes
that's that's one way that we could say
it if we're going to have something like
that
excused as a culture that's absolutely
inexcusable and it's extremely dangerous
not just for the uyghur muslims
but for all the other people that are
going to be under the chinese
umbrella and because of the belt and
road initiative because of
china's goal to become the number one
hegemonic power
a lot of people are going to be
subjugated under china in the near
future
what you just said jack what did you
what did you uh
i said that joe biden neutered american
exceptions no no no no no no no no no
that i'm so talking unrequested uh
insemination
women are being held down so this news
broke a witness came out and said that
her job in the camps was to basically
pin the women down
while the men came in take their clothes
off and then
yeah this was reported by the bbc by
themselves yeah
we also got numerous reports that many
of the women who
on their own of their own volition
became pregnant
had the chinese government paramilitary
forcefully end those pregnancies
so they're forcefully sterilized they're
trying to sterilize the uyghur
population but
force the han genetic code into other
uyghur women yes there's also videos of
children being taken away from their
parents and then being told to repeat
that the chinese government the chinese
state the chinese country is their
mother now
so it's what's happening right now
especially with some of the drone
footage that's been leaked of
individuals being hooded and put on
trains
is absolutely terrifying especially when
you see the larger response
especially when you see on twitter an
embassy from the chinese government
officially say that it's
women's rights that they're promoting
women's equality and women's freedom
when they have these forced
sterilizations on them that's the kind
of
like crazy insane woke language that
they're trying to use to justify this
and you see
you just saw joe biden usher and and
utter
ccp chinese communist party talking
points to the american public
like it was normal where did he get the
talking points from i want to say i'll
say two things the first thing is we had
china uncensored on the show yes
and they said this the biden
administration has people
involved that like what china is doing
in terms of their expansion and have
praised them now i want to read you i
want to read you what uh what biden said
they say uh here's a quo i'll read the
quote i point out to him
i'm assuming this is impang no american
president can be sustained as a
president
if he doesn't reflect the values of the
united states the u.s president
continued
and so the idea that i am not going to
speak out against what he's doing in
hong kong what he's doing with the
uyghurs and western mountains of china
and taiwan trying to end the one china
policy by making it forceful
zee gets it culturally there are
different norms that each country and
their leaders are expected to follow
the norms in china as shown in a recent
bbc news expose
include systemic torture and as we
mentioned women being held down and men
you know coming in and forcing
themselves in these concentration camps
following the release of the bbc report
china banned the outlet in its territory
because it is happening yeah there's
also a new rule in china where bloggers
have to get a government-approved
license and credential to talk about
politics and foreign policy
but you could still talk about
entertainment food and beverages hey so
that's way way way way
where is that china in china the
institute it was it was
close enough to being like that just
happened in the us
for me to be like wait whoa whoa hold on
a second it sounds like what biden's
saying is the only reason he's going to
talk disparagingly about what they're
doing is because he doesn't want to lose
his job
exactly right he has to reflect the
norms of his country
to stay president whereas also he was
saying
that g g g he also has to reflect the
norms of his country
well china's influence is is very vast
they're not only expanding all over the
world but they're expanding with a lot
of multinational billionaire
corporations
that do have a big influence in the
united states whether it's nike
apple disney you name them the ties of
the chinese
money goes to universities goes to a lot
of our key institutions that set
policy so are we at a stage and i think
we should be seriously asking ourselves
where
the chinese have already infiltrated us
successfully and are dictating policies
you got it
and that's not a crazy question to ask i
think that's a legitimate question
they're all over the place just when uh
corona was breaking was that scandal of
the ccp
agents at ivy league institutions
as spies carrying viruses through the us
illegally yeah this story was was i
thought it was going to be a bigger
story
that people who were spies for the
chinese government were smuggling in
viruses no joke i hate that the ccp is
considered the chinese government that's
like calling the nazi party the german
government and they like co-opted that
country through violent
takeover and subterfuge and the like
mao's communist revolution
basically seized control of that country
with a mono party
well they rule with an iron fist they
have a social credit score you say the
wrong thing
in some uh you know jurisdictions in
china they will take you put you in a
police room
tie you down and make you apologize on
camera
doing unspeakable things to you again uh
it was surprising also
also to see a response from naomi wolfe
surrounding this particular issue she
wrote that she wanted her vote back
specifically after seeing this video
with joe biden
but but again another thing i i did i
did a full video about this
on on we are change but i talked about
this because people are always expecting
a hot war between china and the united
states
because we're already at a currency war
a trade war and the next
logical step is a hot war but i think
the war is already being fought and has
fought
with this larger context of generational
warfare it's
here in my opinion and if you look at
what is happening in our schools the
united states is losing it's losing
badly not just with the suicide rates
not just with the increases of mental
uh health uh crisis in in in our schools
not just with the increases of
depression
but but even with masculinity you see
china actively trying to make their boys
more masculine
in the united states we have a lot of
universities a lot of schools talking
about how masculinity
is of course toxic and joe biden just
even got rid of a directive that ends
transparency
of the chinese government with their
ties to american universities you guys
ever played that video game civilization
yeah i played the original me too
civilization two is my favorite
it was awesome but but i have i think
what are we on six now yep
one of the ways you can win is called
the cultural victory yeah
it's where you generate culture that
spreads across the planet
and seeps into all the other nations and
obviously you know
life imitates art art it's life and all
that stuff blue jeans and rock and roll
baby in the game civilization
you can win the game by having your
culture dominate the world it doesn't
matter
if you can control the government of
these countries because your culture
the ideas that spread essentially
dictate the behaviors of the individuals
another thing that happens in the game
is that if you have cities that are
surrounding other
opponent you know other countries cities
and your culture is just you're mass
producing it
eventually those cities request to join
your nation or you can lose your city
i bring that up because it is it's ju
it's just
uh you know art imitates life life
imitates a culture
right now in the united states we have
the nba
praising china defending china this was
a big scandal we have
nba banning free hong kong jerseys
suckling the
teat of china not the united states in
the united states we believe in free
speech we support the right of the
people in hong kong to protest
why would this massive multinational
corporation surprise
you know it's funny the nba has become
that why would they side with china over
us
because we already lost that's it china
even released statements
supporting black lives matter protest in
the united states
joe biden one of the first things he
also did was sign an executive order
banning the term
china virus as soon as he came into
office but of course he keeps talking
about the uk variant for some reason and
doesn't really understand the larger
kind of context surrounding that
but you know we have to understand joe
biden also made a statement a couple
years ago we knew this was coming
everyone saw this coming i mean anyone
paying attention
saw the writing on the wall a few years
ago joe biden said that a rising china
is a positive development he put in a
lot of people in his state department
that also believe
in a similar idea that china rising on
the world stage
helping out the global economy is going
to is going to be good for everyone's
pockets but
pocketbooks not just theirs and exactly
and exactly the people that they serve
since joe biden is a career politician
that is known for always selling out the
people all right i got two things to say
about china you mentioned the word
masculinity i can't let that go so
i'm gonna chime in on that but the first
thing i'm gonna say is that the saddest
most disgusting part this whole thing
about china
is how are they financing the belt and
road how are they financing all
multinational corporations no where did
they get the money dude yeah special
interest
no u.s dollars from us dummies
from all of us buying money buying
things from china and sending them u.s
dollars they are mercantilist
they have stockpiled u.s dollars in u.s
assets and now they're using them to buy
up hard assets
so guys we have traded ports airports
you know transportation hubs
infrastructure for cheap chinese
televisions now the second thing i want
to say
is if china is advocating
masculinity for its men
they know masculinity is a lindy value
masculine people build
create protect provide and instruct
that sounds like a winning combination
for civilization
in america what do we do the american
psychological association
deems masculinity toxic risk taking
competitiveness aggression needs to be
medicated and therapy and
therapeutically removed
from children we have a a a formal
demasculinization policy in america to
make us weak
to make us less build less builders less
of creators less of protectors
less of providers less of instructors
whereas china knows
that that's where the money is and
that's where the power is
and so they're advocating it this is a
new twist and i was not aware and it's
been in the works for a while especially
if you look at the testosterone rates
and the fertility rates in the west
especially in the united states that are
absolutely dropping testosterone right
group testosterone levels are down
fertility and sperm rates are
you know sperm counts are down and i got
we got railed up for this last time i
talked about grip strength
on this show yeah some guy some guy made
a video and just was mocking us the
whole time he's like he got like twenty
thousand views on it because
all about grip strength yes group grip
strength is down why is that important
because it is a
factor is a data point that shows that
men are weak
apparently hanging from tree branches
will help it really it does but we don't
do that anymore
because we keep our boys we keep our
boys locked up inside
medicated restricted and we tell them
that competitiveness and aggression and
winning
winning is bad everybody gets what's
this company you you mentioned
that has said the masculinity is toxic
what's the
american media the american
psychological association
the largest mental health
professional association in america
believes that masculinity is toxic and
must be treated oh that's gross
it's disgusting it's everywhere and by
the way last bit of the rant
it is at the heart of the feminist
argument right all
societies have been patriarchal all
patriarchal societies are oppressive
where does this patriarchal power come
from men what fuels that
masculinity masculine energy how do we
end depression how do we end patriarchy
we've got to eliminate masculine energy
and that is why
to be masculine today is to be a pariah
is to be a political dissident and if
you believe in this come check us out
liminal order very cool
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you